breaking news this hour the ministry of
Defense has confirmed that troops have
been training at Heathrow and Gatwick
airports in passport checking roles that
is ahead of this month's border Force
strikes the mod has confirmed to Sky
News that soldiers arrived at London's
two main airports earlier this week well
two days ago the PCS Union announced
border Force officers will strike at the
two major airport hubs from the 23rd to
the 26th again from the 28th to the 31st
of December within the last few minutes
the Prime Minister Rishi sinak has been
talking about those strikes
so the government is always going to try
and act fairly and reasonably and that's
why we accepted in full the
recommendations of the independent
bodies that advise a government on the
appropriate levels of pay in the public
sector but what I'm not going to do is
ask ordinary families up and down the
country to pay an extra thousand pounds
a year to meet the pay demands of the
union bosses that wouldn't be right and
it wouldn't be fair but what I am going
to do is ensure that I minimize the
disruption to people's lives and make
sure that we protect lives and that's
what we're working on right now with
resilience and contingency plans but
also looking at tough new laws which
will help us do that but you're right
we're here at an RAF Base today I had
the opportunity to say thank you to some
of our Armed Forces Personnel because
many of them are going to miss Christmas
to help us deal with the disruption from
strikes whether that's Manning border
posts or driving ambulances and we all
owe them an enormous debt of gratitude
okay I mean you mentioned there the new
laws you that you spoke about in Commons
to quote the lives and livelihoods of
the British public against strike action
what new laws prime minister do you have
any details or timings no we're looking
at everything right now at PACE but my
priority is going to be to protect lives
and to minimize the disruption on
people's lives so the government is
trying its best to act reasonably that's
why we've accepted in full the
recommendations of independent bodies
who make the recommendations to the
government about pay settlements in the
public sector and often those pay
settlements have been higher than what
many people in the private sector are
receiving but the government accepted
them in full to be reasonable to be fair
but it's right now that we also look to
minimize A disruption on people's lives
and that's why we're looking at tough
new laws okay you said you're looking at
everything there what are we talking
about it was widely briefed to the press
that you could be looking at emergency
workers end up like the police being
Banning been banned from Strike action
yes or no is that on the table so I'm
not going to get into the details now
we're looking at all options but what I
can say is my priority is to always be
reasonable and that's what we're going
to continue to do but also to make sure
that we can protect lives and minimize A
disruption to people's lives that's
that's my focus and that's what we'll
work on doing
well joining us now is our political
correspondent Rob Powell um Rob people
traveling over the holidays using the
airports are going to be fearing chaos
there aren't they just talk us through a
little bit what the contingency plans
are
so as far as they apply to the UK's
borders and the airports and the staff
there that usually do things like
checking passports there'll be 600
Services Personnel that have been
allocated to essentially take the place
of striking workers and some of those
have already been at London Gatwick
Airport in London Heathrow Airport
earlier this week to start training in
essentially Manning those border posts
checking people's passports as they come
into the country and off um the plane
are not flights there now it was
announced about a week ago that in total
there would be 2 000 military personnel
but also volunteers and civil servants
that would be drafted in as part of this
contingency plans that could involve
things like
soldiers troops driving ambulances we
know that there's an ambulance strike
coming up on the 21st of December it
could also include them working as far
firefighters as well fire unions are
balloting at the moment the reason why I
think the first
indication of practical training and
boots on the ground if you like has come
with regards to airports is because we
learned earlier this week that the
public and Commercial Services Union the
PCS Union said that they would be
striking over Christmas now that has the
potential to cause huge disruption at
the border huge delays and cues
potentially for people coming into the
country but also and this is something
the Home Secretary said yesterday would
potentially as she said anyway she
wasn't prepared to allow there to be
security breaches or security problems
at the border so that could be why I
think troops have been focused here
um initially we haven't had any
confirmation of training going on as far
as ambulance drivers
um go it's not without its criticism
though when this strike was announced at
the border among border staff the PCS
Union general secretary actually wrote
To The Head of the Armed Forces urging
him to not allow military personnel to
stand in for striking workers to
essentially ask him to withdraw them
from this task and there's others for in
the military Community as well that have
spoken about how this is potentially an
uncomfortable position for troops to be
put in the former head of the army
General Lord dannett told the Times
newspaper this morning that it was
unreasonable and potentially
controversial to use the Army to take
the place of striking workers others say
that look if you're going to use the
Army to step in when there are strikes
like this then essentially you need to
get a bigger Army if they are going to
take on these tasks as well as their
normal regular duties I think what you
heard In that clip from Rishi sunak
there though is the reason why these
strikes are potentially going to go
ahead in the weeks and months ahead the
government very tightly sticking to its
commitment not to hand out pay Rises
that go um in excess of the current rate
of inflation which is you're not making
the point that he believed that would
mean essentially applicating union
bosses as he saw it and forcing ordinary
taxpayers to foot the bill